Merhaba Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Eee ikinci
yarıda olmak biraz Aslında Tedirgin
edici bir şeydi normalde çok fazla
gençlik etkinliklerine gidiyoruz
üniversitelerde liselerde ve hep bir
Yaprak Dökümü olur E ama istedik ki
gerçekten ben ve bundan sonraki
konuşmacı arkadaşım En azından bu
salondaki insanlarda biraz günün
hatırasını kalabilecek ve ilham noktası
olabilecek bir şey bıraksın Dolayısıyla
kaldığınız için teşekkür ederim eee
çok güzel bir açıklamayla arkadaşlarım
beni sundu e Belki ilk defa
karşılaştığınız Belki yeni yeni duymaya
başladığınız bazı kavramlar özerinde Ben
kesişimsellik teorisini Aslında
anlatacağım Eee Hayat bazen tesadüfler
ve bu tarz kesişimler de çok fazla var
Daha önce de bu hikayeleri dinledik ama
biraz böyle iş dünyasında Daha doğrusu
yetenek dünyasında dünyanın gittiği
rotada e kesişimsellik nerelerde
karşımıza çıkacak çeşitlilik nedir
kapsayıcılık nedir Eee büyük firmalar
neden
alanları sizin i düny dir kend içind
bulacağınız Boriler
bahsettiği
gi firmalar Ben roller
oldu Neye çeşitlilik
diyoruz de veya bir iş yerinde Eee
farklı birbirine benzemeyen birbiriyle
görünür veya görünmeyen belli çizgilerle
farklılıklarla ayrılmış insanların
birlikte çalışması çeşitlilik ve
çeşitlilik neden önemli Eee ve
çeşitliliği tek başına neden Aslında
çalıştıramayan bahsedeceğim inclusion
dediğimiz şey kapsayıcılık yani çeşitli
olmak tek başına yeterli bir kavram
değil aynı şekilde içinde olduğunuz
ortamda sizi farklılıklarını da kabul
edecek bir kültürü de yaratmış olmanız
gerekiyor
her K şu
Dün bütün bütün büyük şirketler üniteler
Odak
[Müzik]
giu bir üzer ve
kabi kesiğim şok akadem
[Müzik]
bir dedim Bütün bunların Tüm bu
çeşitlilikler birbirinden bağımsız ele
alınmaması teorisidir Aslında
dolayısıyla daha çok asl siyasi siyahi
kadınların mesela teknoloji siyahi
kadınların var olması ve temsiliyeti
ortaya çıkmış bir kavramdır
intersectionality ve bazı farklılıklar
birbirleri overlap edebilirler Yani hem
siyahi olmak hem kadın olmak hem
teknolojide çalışıyor olmak birden fazla
katmanlı bir ayrımcılık sizi yüz yüze
getirebilir Dolayısıyla Tam burada bu
kavramların kesişim alanı Aslında bizim
çalışma alanımız Dolayısıyla birbirinden
farklı çalışanları işe aldığınızda E hem
göçmenleri hem türbanlıları hem lgbt
bireylerini işe aldığınızda onlara bir
iş ortamı sunduğunuz göreviniz bitmiş
olmuyor Eee yaşadıkları Birden farklı
farklı katmanlı ayrımcılıkları da aynı
şekilde yönetmeniz ve dahil edici
kapsayıcı bir kültür içinde çalışma
yapmanız
gerekiyor Mesela burada bir çalışan Kın
veya birini
görüyoruz
güell gö
[Müzik]
biriz
IR bizim cinsiyet kimliğimiz toplumsal
cinsiyet kimliğimiz bir konu bir de AGM
Yani aslında yaşlılık yaş ayrımcılığı
Başka bir konu tüm Bunların içinde çok
farklı Bu arada kombinler yapabiliriz
Tüm bu segmentler içinde Peki
kesişimsellik nerede devreye
giriyor Az önce verdiğim o engelli
çalışan kadın çalışan aynı şekilde
teknolojide çalışan yazılımcı engelli
çalışan türbanlı gibi
kombinleyebileceğiniz ul atabileceğimiz
birçok kavram Aslında Eee tam
kesişimsellik alanlarında yakalıyoruz ve
dolayısıyla bu kavramların Hiçbirini
birbirinden ayrı düşünmemiz mümkün değil
Bir örnek üzerinden gidelim bir cinsel
taciz vakasını düşünelim aynı şekilde
benim de içinde olduğum kurumlarda
çalışma alanlarından bir tanesi En
azından şu an içinde olduğum kurum
28.000 çalışanı olan ve onların da
aileleri olan çok büyük bir ekosisteme
sahip çalıştığımız konulardan bir tanesi
evçi şiddet cinsel taciz vakaları ve
sayılar gerçekten
fazlasıyla bizi asında meşgul ediyor ve
şe gösteriyor Ne kadar ilgi ve alakadar
olmanız gerektiğini ve büyük bir firma
olmanın sorumluluğuyla çalışanları bu
konuda etmeniz gerektiğini de söylüyor
Eee bu vakalara bakarken Aslında şunu da
öğreniyoruz bir cinsel taciz vakasında
Eee kişinin etnik kimliğini kişinin
cinsiyetini bağımsız değerlendirebilir
misiniz Bunların aslında ne kadar
ilişkili olduğunu o olayın o şekilde
sonuçlanmasını kişinin etnik kimliğinin
cinsiyetinin dininin yaşının ne kadar
etkin olduğunu Aslında birden fazla ayr
mücadele ettiğini görebilirsiniz tek bir
olay ve tek tekil bir olay üzerinden ele
almamanız gerekiyor Peki mevcutta durum
nasıl şimdi sh girdiniz Google işte
diverse workplace çeşitli bir iş ortamı
çeşitlilik barındıran bir iş ortamı
yazdığınızda şöyle bir işte bir fotoğraf
çıkabiliyor bir Hintli olabiliyor işte
bir engelli bir çalışan olabiliyor
hamile bir çalışan olabiliyor Birden
farklı çeşit ve çok mutlu bir iş ortamı
resmediliyor
bize bir de aslında bütün bu
kapsayıcılığı bir pazarlama aracı hale
dönüştürmüş markalar var şu anda dünyada
Çünkü çok fazla getirisi olan bir şey
Neden Çünkü bizim gibi gençler Hatta
gelmekte olan yeni nesilin bazı
talepleri var yani ben bazı konularda
sosyal konularda taahhütleri olan ciddi
güçlü Tarifleri olan kurumlara hizmet
vermek istiyorum ya da onların bir
parçası olmak istiyorum ideolojisine ve
duruşuna saygı duymadığım bir şirkette
çalışmak istemiyorum gibi çok güçlü bir
Eee Aslında duruşları var Dolayısıyla
markaları Aslında hizaya getiren Bu
anlamda yeni gelen nesil markalar da ne
yapıyor burada çeşitliliğin farklı
segmentlerine her markanın mutlaka bir
tütü var Genelde Amerika'nın önderliğini
ettiği Aslında Amerikan şirketlerin
önderlik ettiği bir pazarlama savaşı var
Bu anlamda bize gelin işte bizim Ne
olursan ol gel sözümüz var ya aslında
Mevlana'nın şu anda herkesin her
şirketin bir mosu haline geldi
Dolayısıyla burada güçlü bir savaş var
bu aslında çok güçlü bir müşteri ve aynı
zamanda yetenek
sı yeni roller Çıkıyor tabi Dedim ya
bizi hizaya Getiriyorlar büyük
şirketlere Yani
biz bunları yapmak durumunda o
insanların bizimle çalışmasını sağlamak
ve mutlu çalışmasını sağlamak için bazı
adımlar atmak durumunda kalıyoruz O
yüzden yeni roller sürüyor bu birazdan
göstereceğim rollerin Şu an akademide
bir karşılığı yok Yani şunu bitirdim
bunu yaptım ve böyle oldum gibi bir
karşılığı yok aynısı benim için de
geçerli Biraz Aslında bu konudaki ilgi
bilgi birikimi Odak noktası
derinleştirdi gayet içine
[Müzik]
her
kavramlarını Aslında denetleyen etik
birimleri
oluşuyor people Experience erg leaders
dediğimiz Bizim Okul kulüpleri gibi
Aslında belli konular etrafında bulunan
çalışanların tamamen employee resource
grou yani Çalışan grupları kuruyorlar
tamamen bir sosyal kulüp gibi ama belli
konularda çalışıyorlar çalışmakla
kalmıyorlar proje üretiyorlar ve
şirketin gidişatını değiştirecek aslında
bütün o busin rotasını değiştirecek
işler ve geliştirmeler sağlıyorlar
dolayısıyla i liderliği yani çalışanlar
HR ve yönetim dışında söz sahibi olan
ciddi ekipler ve insan hakları ekleri
burada cdi tün bu konular asında şirket
kültürü konusunu da getiriyor Eminim çok
duyuyorsunuz bizim kültürümüz böyle
kültür böyle Yek ins özellikle Bun As şu
içinde olduğumuz coğrafyada biraz
liderlik ettiği
şeyler Culture kültür şirket kültürüne
özellikle Ç insanlar var bazı
şirketlerde yel tamamen sorlu bir Neyi
yaratmaya çalışıyor biz yemek Sebi
olarak buna inanırız herkesin eşit bir
şekilde dahil edildiği bir ortam
yaratmak için çalışırız inovatif vesaire
gibi böyle moları var aslında yani her
yerde okuduğumuz şeyler ama bu kültür
kavramı da değişiyor nasıl değişiyor
Culture ölmesinden çok mutlu olduğum bir
kavram yani ölmeye başlamasından çok
mutlu olduğum bir kavram Çünkü Culture
denilen şey aslında az önce size
anlattığım o çeşitlilik çeşitliliğin
getirdiği zenginlik o yeni potansiyel
her o aynı kaynağa eşit şekilde eşit
deneyime ulaşmasını sağlamanın en büyük
engeli Çünkü ben size bir kod veriyorum
bu şirk girmek için böyle bir y olman
lazım bu şmek için 3 üniversiteden mezun
olman lazım İş şunu Yapmış olman
lazımmış böyle giymen lazım gibi belli
kodları yı yıkan
aslında bir şey bize yeni lens
kazandırıyor Peki bizim Burak dersimiz
ne bütün bunları anlattık il
içinde bir iş arkadaşı potansiyel bir iş
arkadaşı mesai arkadaşı olarak veya bir
destekçi Biray olarak veya bir lider ya
bir katkı Sağlı olarak biz ne
yapabiliriz bilinç dışı
ı bu bilinç dışı ı asa Bizim her gün bir
SP gibi bir ersiz gibi üzer çalışmamız
gereken bir şey çünkü bir düşünün bir
gün içinde bilincinin tamamen dışında
kararın ylar söylemleriniz şekil veren
kaç ön yargınız
vardır bir düşünün bunun üzerine Aslında
sizin hayatta gördüğünüz gördüğünüzü
sandığınız şeyin asında tam bir kesişim
ibaret olduğu gösteriyor bizim çok
alakalı bazı objektif gerçeklikler var
Bir de bizim baktığımız düny kendi
içinde olduğumuz inanç normlar
okuyabildim ve inançlarımız biriz Evet
bu böyledir dediğimiz bilin dışı asa
bizim k
[Müzik]
günü
mesela söylemdir böyle bilinir bu dataya
bariz bir gerçeklik olabilir ama
söylemle altı
çizilemeyen yazılım şirketiyle çalışıyor
Kaç yaşına gelmiş hala işte şu an onun
kullandığı programlar 2000'de kaldı gibi
eizin dediğimiz müthiş müthiş bir yaş
ayrımcılığı ezim sadece stajyerlere
gençlere yapılmıyor gençlere yapılmıyor
şirketlerde birlikte Aslında farklı
jenerasyon birlikte çal anle
çalışabilmesi de bir çeşitlilik ve
kapsayıcılık konusudur Dolayısıyla
asında gençlerin de büyük ve kıdemli
insanlara yaptığı yardımcılık söz
konusu yeni stajeri gördün mü çok güzel
bir kız ama acaba nasıl girdi ya acaba
bu stajı nasıl alı ben çok Culture fit
bir insanım beni her yere çağırırlar
bütün şirket etkinliklerine beni
çağırırlar Çünkü ben bu şirketin Culture
molara çok uygunum onlar gibi
davranıyorum Dolayısıyla benim yerim Her
zaman masada
hazırdır ya da koçtan boğaz içinden
mezun olmamış asla bu terfiyi alamaz
asla direktör olamaz gibi yargılar gün
içinde gerçekten hala ne yazık ki
duymaya devam ettiğimiz
şeyler o yüzden bir ürün tasarlarken bir
hizmet verirken E bir konuda Aslında
fikir beyan ederken bazı lensleri takmak
zorundayız Çünkü çok kısa süre sonra siz
de aslında bu filtrelerden geçecek Eee
buralarda belli sınavlar veriyor
olacaksınız iş dünyasında özel
hayatınızda gönüllülükle yaptığınız bazı
hobi aktivitelerinde ve
arkadaşlar Mesela bu lensleri n pratiğe
dökebiliriz diye düşündüğünüz önce şu
soruları sor ben nı herkes için
erişilebilir herkes için kapsı benim
ürünüm nl bu hale gelebilir mesela Emin
bilgisayar oyun oynayanların var şu anda
bu böle anlattığım işte çeşit kapsı
kişileri sadece çalışanları mutlu ve
daha bağlı hissetmelerine sebep olmuyor
ya da sadece bunun için çalışmıyorlar
mesela Games büyük bir oyun
firması çıkaran şey oyun kelimesi Orada
mesela şu anda yepyeni bir departman var
oyunun içindeki canlı oyunu oynarken
nasıl
ayrıştırıcı yorumlarda bulunm bunun
önüne nasıl geçeriz kadın karakterleri
genelde böyle E biraz böyle seksiz şey
bir yerden tasarlıyorlar oyunlarda
Mesela şu an Onun önüne geçmek için
ciddi bir laboratuvar var arkada Yani
biz buna e eşitlikçi bir şekilde o
tekrardan nasıl tasarlar Dolayısıyla Siz
de verdiğiniz ürün hakkında bu soruları
sormanız Eee gerekiyor Eee ve az önce
bahsettiğim İşte o önyargı testlerini O
pratiklerini her gün yapmanız ve
kararlarınızı bu anlamda da sorgulamanız
gerekiyor aynı şekilde birlikte iş
yaptığınız Eee tedarikçilerimiz yani şu
anda yine kendi şirketimden örnek
verebilirim Garanti BBV fotokopi
hizmetini veren şirket bile çayını
sabununu aldığı şirket bile belli
taahhütleri vermek zorunda bizimle
çalışıyorsan eee bu bu bu eğitimleri
çalışanlarına vermek zorundasın
diye ciddi kontrolünü yaptığımız ve Aksi
halde Kesinlikle çalışmadığımız ve onun
büyümesine destek olmadığımız bir
sistemi size anlatmış olım Bunlar çok
yeni gelişmeler Google'ın dünyada
öncülük ettiği şeyler yani Google artık
saplar Ç tedarik zincirinde diyor ki ben
asla cinsiyetçi ayrımcı ırkçı firmalarla
bu tarz söylemleri olan firmalarla asla
çalışmıyorum Dolayısıyla etki alanına
bakın yani 28.000 çalışanı olan bir yer
aileleri onlara dokunuyoruz aynı şekilde
çalıştığımız binlerce tedarikçi
şubelerimiz tüm Türkiye
Yani bir yan da o hizalanma dediğim şey
aslında bizi mecbur bıraktıkları zorunda
bıraktıkları şeylerin olumlu etkisine
bir bakın Dolayısıyla yine
do Yani siz de kendine baktığımda ben bu
işi kimle yapıyorum işte bugün bir haber
okudum Mesela işte Melek
mun şeye gidememesi konsere gidememesi
onun yerine işte çok cinsiyetçi olduğu
bilinen başka bir sanatçının yerine
konması bu bile aslında şeyi gösteriyor
kimlerle çalışıyorum ben kimlere para
kazandırıyorum Dolayısıyla benim bir iş
Ortağım bu sebepten eleniyor yerine kimi
koyuyorum Aslında bu lenslerle çok da
karar verilmemiş oluyor Bunu da o
örnekte
görebiliyoruz eşitlik kadın için erkek
için ve tüm toplumsal cinsiyet rolleri
için Şimdi bu konuları aslında bütün
bunları anlattım Çünkü bir de böyle
yutması zor en azından bizim için bazı
gerçeklik
[Müzik]
mesel
8.8
şek Uz yıllar olacak bir konu Eee
nedenini bilmediğimiz bir şekilde aynı
işe aynı deneyimi aynı okuldan mezun
olan insanların farklı maaş teklifleri
alması farklı zam farklı prim Eee
yaptırımlarından Aslında yararlanması ve
dolayısıyla o erkekle kadın çalışanın
arasındaki farkın payg diyoruz buna yani
o ödeme ücret farkının yıllar geçtikçe
arttığı bir senaryoyu gözlemliyoruz şu
anda e birçok şirket Şu an bunu önlemek
için çalışıyor ama Eee % 56 oranında
erkekler kadınlar daha fazla kazanıyor
her Kriter eşken yani eşitken
Peki economic for dünya ekonomik Zirvesi
2020 raporunda şöyle bir açıklama var
yani ben bunu okuduğumdan beri aslında
bütün çalışmalarım biraz buraya
odaklandı Eğer buza gidersek yani e eşit
ücretin verilmediği % aynı oranda
artmaya devam ederse bu açığın kapanması
995 yıl sonraa gerçekleşebilecek
Dolayısıyla önümüzde gerçekten uzun bir
yol var kadın erkek 50 eşli değil yani
bir üniv şu üniversitelerde ofisleri
Varisleri var çalışıyorlar oralarda işte
kadın mülteci öğrenciler almaya
çalışıyorlar Bir çeşitlilik yaratmaya
çalışıyorlar ama bu konu sadece işte
yarı kadın varsa yarı da erkek olsun
kadınlar şu ücre alıyorsa erkekler Bun
alsın Bir tık daha ötesinde eşit As tam
orada 50 Target yakalamanın çok daha
ötesinde herkes için eşit fırsatlar
yaratmak Aslında bu mücadelenin adı
rakamsal bir hedefin çok daha ötesinde
Bunun için de Heey yolumuz
var teşekkür
ederim